whoa they're my party people have my
party boys and girls we're quarantine
baby well I heard they weren't gonna let
sick people get off this boat I grab one
of those Filipino lady boys who was
restocking a buffet and I deep mouth
kiss them listen I feel sick as [ __ ] all
the time at home I might as well be on a
[ __ ] boat I said to my wife you dumb
[ __ ] next time they ask how you're
doing you cough I would even talking
about just cost me the door I'll never
leave it this [ __ ] thing we're in
[ __ ] paradise they put food right
outside the door we just open it we just
eat and [ __ ] and float got a little
leather mask look real stylish I feel
like a deflector this is my 17th cruise
usually they spray us down with anti
germs [ __ ] before we eat they spray a
sound like pigs walking into a
slaughterhouse they doused beating my
wife with ammonia didn't affect us one
bit I love my wife and if she dies I'll
take another your [ __ ] did
[ __ ] Canasta virus [ __ ] your head up
even if they find a cure I will refuse
the medicine because I am happily sick
with the lime in it babe wasting it away
again in quarantine Ervil if they make
me get off this boat I'm gonna infect
every [ __ ] in this country